let's have a look at taking safety
advice and see who's looking out for
your safety on fan its beaches do you
think all fan its beaches have
lifeguards on them in the summer no they
don't only some of the beaches are
patrolled by lifeguards here in fannin
now let's show you which ones they are
did you recognize those beaches all
these beaches of life guards patrolling
them looking out for your safety or i
will i will just keep on them although
lifeguards will give you advice we can't
enforce it and that part's up to you but
we can't be everywhere at once so we use
flags to help you keep safe but do you
know what all the flags mean it means
that they're on any lifeguards on the
beach ah does it mean to save this room
cuz life cosmo that's right if you see
red and yellow flags you know that
lifeguards are on the beach and it's
safe to swim you will find these flags
at each lifeguarded beach from may until
sep tember and how about this flag
it's swimmable but it's really really
really cool ah I think it means that
there's too many jellyfish around does
it mean no swimming that's right you
should not enter the water for any
reason when you see this flag the red
flag will be flying if the sea is too
rough to swim in there are strong
offshore winds or perhaps a swarm of
jellyfish have come close to the shore
flags are not the only thing you should
look out for on the beach there are many
different types of signs all along fan
its coastline warning you of potential
dangers they are not there to spoil your
fun but they are there to help you stay
safe although the lifeguards are not on
duty all year round some signs and
public safety equipment remain on the
beaches
it's my job to go around all the beaches
in fan it all year round and check the
public rescue equipment in case it's
needed in an emergency you should always
pay attention to the safety signs and
look for the flags to let you know if
it's safe to swim if you can't see
anything ask a lifeguard if there is one
or play it safe and stay on the beach
you